Let's look at a different example. So for the sake
of illustration, I've increased the cost between x and z
to 50, and now everyone starts with a different set
of initial distance vectors. Now eventually, after running the distance vector
protocol, we would see the tables converge as such. Let's
suppose that the cost of the link between x and y
suddenly increased from 1 to 60. Well now in this
case, y would need to update Its view of the shortest
path between Y and X. Now its no longer
one, but its not 60 either. To see why let's
go back to our Bellman-Ford equation. We can see that
Y thinks it can get to Z with a cost
of two, and that Z can get to X with a cost of three. So in fact it's going to
update this entry from one to five. Then it will
tell it's neighbor z it's new distance vector. In other
words, that now its distance to x is no
longer one but five. At this point, z needs
to re-compute it's shortest path to x. Now, it
knows that it can get to y with a cost
of two but it thinks still that y can get to x with a cost of five. Therefore,
this entry is no longer three but seven. And
now z sends it's new distance vector back to y.
Y then updates it's distance vector for z and
this process continues. So then, y thinks it is
now nine units away from x. So z has to do this all over again and now z thinks
that its shortest path is two plus nine or
11. And this process repeats, of course, until z
finally realizes that it has a shorter path of
50 directly through x. After this counting up process exceeds
the value of 50. This problem is called
the count to infinity problem, and the solution
is called poison reverse. The idea here is that if y must route through z to
get to x in its table, as it did here, then y advertizes an infinite cost
for the destination x to z. So instead
of sending five, zero, two, y would send infinity,
zero, two. This would thus prevent z from routing back through y and
Immediately, it would choose, the shortest path to x, of path cost 50.